can you use a gift card on a first date  yes i encourage it please use a gift  card on the first date first of all i  don't think dates should cost money your  first date should definitely not cost  money it should be a walk it should be  something boring it should be where you  get to know somebody because that way  you can know if you want to spend the  money and also what kind of money to  spend you take somebody that's not used  to a fancy restaurant to a fancy  restaurant now you just set the tone for  the rest of your life i said use a gift  card  no this is something i know i know i  know more about dating than being  homeless to be honest with you